[Music]
i'll get into a great flow state working
on something but distractions always
seem to find me how do i deal with
unavoidable interruptions
um
amishi unavoidable interruptions we're
talking about distractions today
unavoidable interruptions now
most interruptions are avoidable i think
we can start there we are interrupting
ourselves all the time we set ourselves
up in environments
that
interrupt us constantly the pings the
notifications the emails the social
media streams the facebook post the tick
tock all of a sudden we're interrupted
all day we've signed up for many of our
interruptions
but even if we get rid of those we turn
off the notifications we check the inbox
once a day we remove email from our
phone we remove social media from our
phone there will always be unwelcomed
interruptions in our lives as long as we
are you know living in a society with
other people yeah can we talk about
those yeah but even if we did that even
if we moved away from a society with
other people
and we set ourselves up to do something
let's say i'm going to go on a retreat
in the forest
i'm going to write this
paper manuscript or poem whatever it is
and so there are no extra interruptions
that should be pulling me away
i guarantee there's going to be
interruptions that are unwelcome that
still occur because your mind is still
with you
and there's this great story about these
um medieval monks that literally were
monastics
uh that dedicated their
lives to god like you know hundreds of
years ago and they were getting so
irritated because they'd be praying and
all of a sudden they'd have a thought
about lunch
or they'd have some sexual fantasy that
would arise like they were constantly
getting distracted they would get so
angry with themselves
because the mind just would not stop
pumping out thoughts
and so the first thing i want to say to
everybody that's has distractions that
are maybe unavoidable and external or an
internal
fluttering that can arise is that's
normal like it happens what you do next
is what it may be more in your control
so the first step is to notice that it's
occurred i am distracted right now my
mind is not where i want it to be you
know the flashlight i want pointing here
but it's over here that is huge that's a
huge win to say my mind is not where i
want it to be
but then that gives you permission and
instruction to do something else which
is oh now that i know i'm not where i
want it to be bring it back
so it's focus notice redirect
and that by the way is the exact same
set of components that are part of a
foundational mindfulness practice
that we can do over and over again and
then the distractions have less power
over us because the reason i think
people get so panicked about
distractions just like those medieval
monks did
is they think that they're gonna be
compelled to interact with them in that
hyper proliferating manner that clutters
the entire white board and then you're
toast and it's like i can't even think
anymore all i see is like a thousand
thoughts right so
so instead
if you really hone in on this capacity
to notice what's going on you have other
choices that you could make either
continue in that proliferation or just
simply return that flashlight back to
where you want to focus um
so begin again what were the three
things again notice focus focus notice
redirect okay so you were describing uh
ryan at the outset that you did the uh
find your flashlight practice you were
doing the breathing exercise yeah uh
last night to fall asleep i think one of
the reasons uh so can i just describe
what that is yeah absolutely
so that breathing practice uh again i
call it the find your flashlight
practice is essentially take a few
moments sit in a quiet place
upright not up tight kind of you're
taking this seriously
notice that your body's breathing just
broadly
and then notice something vivid about
the fact that you are breathing
vivid really vivid in your sensory
experience like the coolness of air
moving in and out of your nostrils or
your chest moving up and down whatever
it is for you
that's the target for your attention
that's the anchor for your attention and
then for the few minutes of the practice
you're going to take your flashlight of
attention and point it on those
breath-related sensations for me it
tends to be the
air in the nostril so i keep my
flashlight there
focus
focusing it there that's the intention
second step
notice when your mind has wandered away
from that focus
so you're and that is by the way that's
where you're using the floodlight that
metaphor of that broad receptive stance
so you're constantly constantly kind of
watching where is my mind right now
i didn't say if you're one of those
weirdos whose mind wanders everybody's
mind will wander 50 of our waking
moments the mind will monitor so you're
focused on that breath-related sensation
you notice
that the mind has wandered
so focus notice third step redirect
redirect
and so this can be very helpful in every
single thing we do the the power of
distractions will be dialed down the
power of uh being overtaken by our own
thoughts will be dialed down and for you
last night i think it probably helped
you fall asleep because that whole
proliferation of mental content
quiets it actually is a way we can quiet
because there's only one thing i'm
focused on
breath yeah yeah because what happens
you know as we're laying down as i'm
laying down going to sleep like i'm
unpacking the day so i'm like we're
living the day and then uh i i will
start thinking about the the next day
and all these stories start to develop
and what's nice about this practice is
yeah it puts you in the present moment
and kind of cuts those stories out and
when i have less chatter in my mind yeah
it's easier for me to fall asleep so
what i hear you saying is like it's not
about
you know like to answer melinda's
question it's not about
avoiding
these distractions it's about how do you
handle these distractions when they come
up because they will inevitably come up
um yeah i mean i think avoiding is like
a tricky thing i would say definitely
advantage yourself to try to monotask
versus putting yourself in a context
where you feel you're going to have to
do multiple things
so try to minimize that just like you
were starting out by saying we can
control some of that realize that even
if you perfectly do that there are going
to be interruptions just emergent things
that come up you might get a phone call
because you need to take it
but more than that notice that
the mind internal distractibility will
continue and there's nothing to really
worry about about it just notice that
it's happening
and don't all don't sort of take the
bait if you will noticing means you've
got control like do i want to keep
having the thought about tomorrow
morning do i really need to think more
about the plans for tomorrow ask
yourself that
right and then if you decide in that
moment yeah you know i still do really
want to sort that out fine but if you
say you know what i'm trying to fall
asleep right now didn't you plan
tomorrow's entire day
get back yeah so that just gives you so
many more choice points
and you're not so compelled by the
distraction
and definitely your chances of becoming
overwhelmed by the distraction may be
dialed down yeah
can you just speak a little bit to so
you have a practice uh some practices in
your book
and like these are these have been
tested on athletes they've been tested
on uh marines
what like if someone reads your book and
they they put these practices in the
life what's the hard data that says like
it actually helps this is how you get
you know the peak mind yeah
and that's kind of why i wanted to write
the book in the first place is because
we kept seeing over and over again a
couple of patterns the first is that
attention is extremely powerful like the
way people pick pay attention and their
ability to do so impacts their
performance and their well-being so they
feel better they're more capable
they're more successful at what they're
trying to achieve they're more fulfilled
by what they want to achieve very
important
so we knew that that was attention is
going to be important but the second
piece which was really the eye opening
piece is it's extremely vulnerable so
under high stress and it may not be you
know something you know is going to
happen you may be landing in the middle
of it you know family member gets sick
or there's a challenge with something
happening with your house you're you
never know right there's it's not maybe
preparing for deployment to war but
they're going to be periods of time
where stress will occur it'll be
protracted
and your attention declines that is
consequential
so
attention's powerful vulnerable so then
the solution was like let's just train
for it let's train every day in the same
way we train for our physical wellness
because we never know when the next high
stress interval may
may occur
so the data itself was us tracking with
objective measures and even in the
larger field of of my field now
contemplative neuroscience we're going
to track with brain imaging we can track
people's brain function
to see what happens is attention
actually objectively less effective
under high stress yes now let's give
mindfulness training in that interval
the suite of practices in this book are
essentially from the wisdom traditions i
didn't really i may have modified them
for a modern twist to give imagery and
examples that make it more accessible
but these have been around at the core
for thousands of years and they're not
mine alone they're they're really part
of the world's wisdom
but
doing them with regularity about 12
minutes a day for four to four to six to
eight weeks you know around four weeks
is a good ramp up
produced protection against decline in
attention
protect protection against decline in
mood
and a reduction in stress levels
so that was the objective stuff and then
we can look at like brass tax
performance how do people actually
perform and you know study we just came
out with recently uh was in military
service members and they got this uh
mindfulness program over uh four weeks
mindfulness based attention training we
wanted it to sound tough so it was mbat
was the acronym
and we gave it to them in the
pre-deployment interval and and yes
unfortunately things got bad and their
attention started declining they took
the program and and were able to stay
stable over time a collaborating group
of army researchers took that same
program and offered it to people and
found that pass rates on something
called the stress shoot which is
essentially they stress them out you
know they do physical activity and then
they have to hit their mark on
marksmanship
they were better at doing that and this
is very important it's not just that
they were better at shooting it's they
were better at shooting when they were
supposed to and withholding when they
were supposed to
so think about what that could mean for
any other people where their actions or
inaction are consequential
so that's the objective data that we've
been looking at yeah no i love that um
because yeah there's a there's an
experience in the book you talk about
um yeah this certain commander has the
authority to like bombard this town and
he was like well hold on like let's just
double triple check let's you know let's
take that flashlight and really focus
and because of his caution he realized
like oh wow these are a bunch of
civilians it could have went way wrong
if he didn't have that ability yeah
that's right to not take action
kind of uh ballistically without thought
and without
planful you know understanding of the
situation yeah yeah no you know what's
cool about this too is there's no like a
there's no woo-woo to it like that's
what i like about really like about your
book one of the things is just how there
is hard data to back up everything that
you're talking about the other thing too
and you even kind of bring this up in
your book
there's there's not anything like even
spiritual about it it's just hard data
there was like the experience of the the
general or someone who
at first was kind of like looking at
meditation like it was a hinduism or
buddhism he was like associating some
type of religious spiritual beliefs with
it and then as he started to look into
it he realized like oh wow this is just
like practical stuff
yeah and you know i thank you for
mentioning that because you know what
verse say like i honor people's
religious spiritual traditions people
should be able to do whatever they want
but i'm a brain scientist and i did this
work from my expertise as a scientist
really wanting to see uh fundamentally
could we train attention
and if we did so could we benefit
people's lives so it's a cognitive
training approach that i took
and so and frankly i would say i
myself even though i'm an indian woman
and heard about mindfulness and
meditation since i was a kid seeing my
parents meditate
i never really thought it was something
that could be taken seriously from a
scientific perspective i was kind of a
skeptic like yeah that's great for you
but not really what hard-nosed
scientists are going to do
i had to overcome my own
my own biases against mindfulness
because frankly out of all the different
things that we studied in the lab it was
the only thing that reliably
repeatedly benefited attention and so we
can add on you know whatever uh sort of
broad cultural religious spiritual
container supports that for the
individual they should feel free to use
that i'm just saying that when we take
it at this level from a brain science
perspective it does seem to be training
the brain in a successful and beneficial
manner
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free